hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
spider-man and I'm Peter Parker
Myles Gwen thanks for joining me today
we will remember Tony Stark yeah you
guys want to hit that off it's probably
very uncomfortable if you guys haven't
seen our reaction to the official
trailer which is essentially trailer
number two for spider-man far from home
go check that out right away now we're
gonna do our breakdown of the trailer
and potential possible spoiler warnings
we're probably gonna be wrong on most
things but actually in the Avengers end
games breakdown we do another half so
possible I want to immediately talk
about something that's not gonna be in
the movie I'll be very fascinated if
it's Tom Holland at the beginning saying
not to watch this trailer it just made
me wonder is this gonna be a load if it
played right before any game oh yeah
you'd only have a couple seconds to get
out because like the very first beat of
the trailers Tony is Peter mornings yeah
a big part of this trailer is obviously
you know not just Peter and not just
happy groovin over the loss of Tony
Stark Iron Man see that the whole world
sort agreement over the loss of Iron Man
here there were two specific shots where
you see paintings of Iron Man on walls
like everything remember the iron man
it's like Superman Batman V Superman the
world more mourns well there are a lot
of fans in the comments going off about
like Oh what if Miles Morales did those
murals ooh multiverse and it was funny
is the first painting that did look like
something out of spider-verse that would
be pretty cool especially because
they're introducing the concept of the
multiverse it could actually be linked
to the spider-verse I do think it's a
good touch to have the big effect not
just be post snap a lot of the theme of
the trailer isn't oh all these people
are back now after the snap a lot of
these people you know half the world's
population is back now it all seems to
be very centrally focused on the hero
that is Tony you know like that's what
everyone's really grieving over I
thought there might be a little bit more
talk about oh all these people are back
now who've been dead for five years or
been vanished for five years but
like the main focus is going towards
Tony Stark well cuz he's the new Jesus
of them's he is the one guy who gave of
himself to bring everyone back you know
I can very much see why they would have
him just sort of as this figure now you
know beyond yeah I'm sure everybody's
happy to have their family members I
would I would suspect though that
they're gonna have to talk about you
know half the universe come back and
also because I would assume some of the
students from spider-man far from or
from homecoming we're not part of this
snapping and the decimation and they
were probably in college now and then
there's definitely the core group who'd
like Flash Peter MJ Ned yeah Eddie they
were obviously snapped cuz they're still
in high school
Peter got very lucky that all his best
friends as the trailer keeps going like
a big part of this relationship that's
forming is Tony was like a surrogate
father for Peter Parker now it seems
like happy is taking on that mantle for
Peter Parker as you see an Avengers end
games obviously gonna be end games
spoilers energy an endgame he's gonna be
looking after Morgan I was looking after
Peter Parker he's still getting the rich
boy treatment you know he seemed well
going on the private plane with happy in
there and I do like had their
relationship him and happy as matured
cuz and kind of been Civil War and also
we see some stock footage in homecoming
a plane trip to Germany we see that
happy can't kind of stand I'm like dude
we got thin walls here like all right
you never been on a plane before it's
like you see that real active definitely
maturing a lot more again seeing that
father side figure my biggest question
in this trailer is happy looking for
cheeseburgers for morning
and American cheese the biggest pale
like I says I don't think Tony would
have done what he did if he didn't know
you were gonna be her after he was gone
Tony did this whole thing just for Peter
Park it's just all up here I'm just
messing with you guys
even though it was a very big motivation
they did have that moment in hanging at
the photo in this kitchen so yeah it's a
nice touch to keep going through here
and you also do see some more cool stuff
with the iron spider suit that didn't
see before when he's you know jacking
out some of those guys in the restaurant
a lot more elaborate web effects webbing
by the walls yeah more spidery things to
do which i thought was fun it feels more
like out of the Spider Man ps4 game yeah
I mean I'm like you guys I'm a huge fan
of hand-to-hand combat fight
choreography and again in those small
little snippets we saw I thought it
looked pretty cool like seeing multiple
guys attacking him at once then he's
using the iron spider suit like with the
iron legs
they acted to just like mess around with
those guys and then you know web Muppet
just look like really cool attacks and
they had combat I mean the fact that he
even though there's other remain many
other remaining Avengers left even some
who are based out in New York City I get
why people will might be like are you
the next Iron Man especially because
he's rocking this iron spider suit which
has so much started tech involved in it
yeah from what I gather from this
trailer it seems like Peters big primary
like B story but real emotional
motivation I imagine it's something a
lot because you see that Ned is clearly
with Betty Brant oh yeah in the rigging
hands we at every clip of Ned that isn't
just him and Peter it's him yeah even in
the International spot you do see them
together when they're about to board
plane or something like that and a lot
of this motivation for Peter seems he
wants to go on this vacation reconnect
with his friends and really tell MJ that
he's in love with her and stuff and then
you also get a line later in the trailer
which is him you know having sort of a
classic superhero debacle which is on
the move seeing Peter Parker really get
into in other spider-man films outside
of the MCU always will have
my friend Damien I feel like a real
emotional context with this specific
spider-man story is him trying to get in
touch with what he truly values most
which would make sense you come back
from the dead
essentially and you're probably gonna
re-evaluate what you're gonna prioritize
like in the first movie is all about I
want to be an adventure I want to be an
Avenger in this movie he's going I mean
Noreen Nick Fury yeah I just want to be
with my friends I want to be with my
friends I want to go on vacation I want
to enjoy my life this time
well what's also interesting to me is
that with that absence a lot of people
point out you've pointed out from the
first movie of Uncle Ben and his impact
on Peter granted that was an origin I
feel like the stuff with Tony and the
grief that subplot story will kind of
take on some of that life of what the
Uncle Ben's story would have given us in
this context because that's a huge
mentor figure those themes of power and
responsibility definitely came up in
last movie through Tony so yeah I got
imagine both the love and then yeah
that's sort of Uncle Ben and quality are
gonna be the and also at the end of
homecoming we did start to see that
mature side of Peter like accepting like
hey I just want to be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man I don't want to
go on a avenger adventures or live in a
room next to vision but I kind of just
want to you know hue my own little thing
even my friends and just again be
friendly neighborhood spider-man so we
did start to see that again at the end
of homecoming and obviously it's lost
and even more into this film well I do
want to point out a little Easter Egg
that we discovered what happy is talking
with Peter of pretty much about wanting
of a Nordic fury there's a sign in the
background and I'm imagine this is
somehow linked to the first trailer when
Aunt May they're presenting a check or
something like that or there's some kind
of a yeah and in the background you see
a sign that says that Forest Hills or
stills is where Peter Parker has grew up
in the comics and as a sign of crusher
Hogan crusher Hogan Joseph crusher Hogan
I believe is actually the inspiration
for bone saw in the first spider-man
movie because his origin and there was
about you know trying to get a hundred
bucks under in a wrestling ring for
under three minutes and earn a hundred
dollars you know that is the bone saw
character and so it seems like it's a
nod to that let's just call us what it
is Joseph Hogan is the long-lost son
okay I actually did get a kick out of
that shot when flash is saying he's
insane Marco Polo and he's posing with
two girls he gets hit in the crotch
because you're seeing this transgression
Flash Thompson who is a bully like his
character is a bully in this image he's
getting bullied what about also inspire
man Home Coming where he's like I say
penis you say partner yeah it's in the
piece that's what happens when you talk
about all the times you get it there
even calls Peter [ __ ] in the first
and the other trailer dick what is it
I've something about a penis alright now
we're really getting to the meat and
potatoes here the seeds the roots or
some some some deeper word that I could
come up with it I didn't pull an
all-nighter this movie feels way more
like a spy movie sandy uh yeah it feels
like Mission Impossible when they're
underneath the tunnel they're you're
more the Mission Impossible is there a
spy aesthetic oh yeah and everything
about this trailer is feeling very spy
aesthetic oh yeah when you get the
tactical suit towards the end which I
mean some of those are so exciting
things to me
seeing those espionage times it's cool
to have that genre blunt in here and
Nick Fury working with Quentin back and
here's where we get some interesting
information we're back says he's from
Earth just not ours that the snap tore a
hole in our dimension that there's a
multiverse out there it's our reaction I
was saying that this could just be some
made-up elaborate sci-fi story Quentin
Beck seems to be a character who is
especially is this this rendition he
seems to be borrowing a lot from other
different famous MCU characters a little
bit of thorn here a little bit of Doctor
Strange in here Iron Man but did mention
in Doctor Strange they talked about the
multiverse a few times in that film like
how they you know they do generate their
powers through other dimensions a
variety verse Baron Mordo and said in
that movie the bill comes due I mean
because when they tamper with the
natural order of nature and obviously
they messed with time in a major way in
Avengers endgame so maybe this could be
the repercussions only of the snap of
them messing with time so perhaps or
just a made-up [ __ ] maybe just
taking advantage of something he knows
could be out there I feel like it might
be it could for all we know it actually
could be cool if it was a combination of
both maybe he is from another earth
maybe there is a
multiverse they are expanding that
they're sony's really trying to push to
get that linked by her spider-verse
minhas and Stuber spider-gwen that could
be the case and then Mysterio could
still be a bad guy some people I've seen
in the comments of theorized that
perhaps it'll come down to something
where Beck wants to save his own earth
and so he won't be like a flat-out
malicious villain but because of the
odds he's at with Peter with what's
going on on this earth or whatever if
that happens to be the case maybe that
will be kind of the thrust of the
conflict there as cool as that would be
this is probably just a case of a
struggle with expectation because I was
I'm really I was really looking forward
to the special effects artists coming in
here yeah I was looking forward to all
that that concept like that would be
cool maybe that is still part of his
backstory but I was kind of looking
forward to just the con artists yeah
yeah yeah I mean they did kind of change
up the scrolls a little and Captain
Marvel because normally they're really
bad and then the emcee is not they're
not shy from changing up or Janet and it
doesn't mean all scrolls are good that
just means that specific group of
scrolls thank God you clarify that yeah
I just piss off the world you know sorry
guys with Peter grieving he's definitely
gonna step in and be some kind of
inspiration or perhaps a mentor figure
you know working together
I gotta imagine that that's shot with
the glasses at the end I of the trailer
I have to imagine where he's gonna
figure out or maybe Tony leaves him some
kind of cliche oh my god yeah oh he's
not a good guy after all
yeah you know like I gotta imagine
that's gonna play out that way I mean
what I'm finding interesting about what
they're doing with the Quinn it with the
BEC marketing specifically they're
really trying to sell us that he's a
good guy
and I don't think anyone who's a
spider-man fan has even the slightest
familiarity with Quentin Beck is gonna
buy that it would be so cool to me if
you find out he's just making up this
whole backstory in the trailer you
pointed out that he has a wedding ring
in there and he's talking about houses
being a hero sometimes involves
sacrifices and people and people die
something he says someone lying in there
about loss maybe there's something with
that wedding ring linked to I lost my
wife you know and it would be so fun to
me if that was just a made-up story he
was doing you know we've seen like shots
of the elementals it's just like
interesting because we're thinking that
these could be visual you know effects
that he's coming up with but then we see
all the destruction
yeah unless he's really good at making
bombs you know people have theorized
that these elementals are just illusions
you know but your seat you're obviously
seeing a lot of very physical
repercussions that are happening with a
lot of you know major destruction
happening in Europe thank God it's not
in America you do get some shots of the
elemental characters in here and you
break it down hi guys basically in the
comics there for immortals who have
basically they have really supernatural
powers you got Hellfire the wielder of
the flame
you got hydrant the Lord of the waters
Magnum not the condom but the master of
the earth and then also you got Zephyr
who is the mistress of the winds yeah
and in that with going off of as the
third I remember people were theorizing
how that is that shot of that one bridge
where lightning striking down if it's
the London Bridge right I believe that's
the George Washington Europe people
thought that could be a zephyr and then
actually in this shot in the trailer you
do get more of a humanoid figure coming
out from the clouds there's a lot of the
theme about this seems and you used to
be briefly touch of this in our reaction
of how people are saying the world needs
another Iron Man even when they're
talking about that towards the end of
the trailer you talk about it adjure
there's something where Peter has a
hologram thing right yeah I can't kind
of harping back a little to Iron Man
when he's creating the Mark 2 and Mark 3
suits and he's like doing that hugger
and then we see that shot from happy
words you know I guess that I don't know
what want to see a nostalgic look but
it's like looking like you almost like
he's seen Tony like yes very eyes a new
and younger Tony I wonder if in that
scene he's either flirting with the Iron
Man or a maybe discovering some kind of
upgrade or new Spider Man serum Oni
would have been working on or something
like that I could definitely see happy
hooking up with Aunt May in this movie
too that would be so cool that's the
what the fans have been asking that
would be so cool and it's gonna be
graphic now really I love all this stuff
with happy tried to make himself a
partner and I just think which guy who
works for someone Andrew you noticed
this when we were making some notes that
was the first time anyone's actually
ever called Carol Jeffers Captain Marvel
never actually heard that name like hey
you're Captain Marvel right captain
unavailable and they were also talking
about Thor how he's off plan cuz he's
you know part of the as guardians of the
galaxy now yes yes so many things so
yeah this trailer was very spoiler heavy
MJ's like you're spider-man right yeah
until she was being normal sarcastic so
busting his balls also drop and also too
at the end of homecomings like where are
you going Peter I'm just kidding again I
feel like after everything the world has
gone through even if she is being
sincere in that tone I'd buy it if this
was pre-snap
I would expect a little bit more of a
reaction I guess to that information
even her just revealing that she knows
but after everything that's been going
on I feel like it would make more sense
for that character to just be like
you're spider-man I put her together
going one of two ways either she figured
it out cuz I believe that because
they've established her as a sharp
character or it's it's a very wry MJ
like I'm busting your balls but I don't
realize I'm right yeah I mean guys if
you think about she had five years of
being dead to think this through yeah
I'm hoping that in this movie we learn a
little bit more about is it gonna be one
of those things where yeah I was gone
for five years but I don't remember any
of it or are we gonna get a hint at
where they were possibly gone to you
know I might be wrong I think there was
a line an end game where Peter said like
we've gone for five years I don't really
remember much but then way so Doctor
Strange it's like oh we gotta go hope I
don't remember oh yeah I'm thinking I
think we might get something I would
like to get summon for me yeah and then
I go snap them all to a specific resort
yeah a lot of people think that this
film will end on a shot of of Peter
looking up and going I am spider-man and
so you know bringing it full circle you
know Tony you know mentorship and all
that that would not be necessary over
the Iron Man mantle actually people are
very excited about that in the in the
comments in terms of being the lead like
of the MCU and stuff but not going by
Iron Man coming
but I am spider I'm all for a they could
do that in reference to like the civil
war comics unmask ourselves well guys
what theories do you have about Mysterio
what's really going on with him do you
think these elementals are real
comment below for a wrap this up I'll
let's get a patron today shout out to a
man named totally jumbled TJ you lucky
dog you he came out to visit LA and I
said sure come with us to go watch
Avengers n game and he did and let me
tell you the guy bawled like a little
baby yeah he has a one-year-old daughter
so all the father-daughter stuff in the
movie made him ball and I had to sit
next to his crying ass the whole time in
the finale of endgame I mean was I
crying too yeah but he was just crying
uncontrollably get your emotions
together man do you want your daughter
to see you like that let in all fairness
I was pretty much behaving that way the
first time I saw it in the second time I
saw it I was with you but I have every
right to criticize you regardless
because that's what I do
I really wish both of you hadn't blown
your noses right into the sleeves of my
shirt though I knew I shoulda got you
guys those tissues it was good to see
you totally jumbled it's good to hold
your hand throughout the cinematic
experience Oh what you don't like my
this contributions meeting you to it the
theaters really cool subscribe click
that notification bell follow Andrew on
the movie source channel this guy
clearly knows what he's talking about
check us out patreon we got plenty of
goodies see you guys